how you doing I want to know how is your
face it looks creamy smooth but clearly
you've been preparing for this yeah hey
guys Chris Pratt here backstage at the
mass singer so excited to sing my hit
song the star is born I will be singing
shallow feel it know don't know just be
it's really it's really soft it could be
a real problem
I stopped rubbing your face you play a
really bad guy how did you get into that
well you know Vincent D'Onofrio is an
amazing director and also you know an
extraordinary actor and his work we've
worked together before a couple of times
and I always was picking his brain he's
a real student of the art form and and
he just kind of got a great performance
you know out of everyone and then in the
film something I've never done before so
it was pretty cool what do you think I
do you heard one hair on his head I'm
taking my nephew with me every single
one of these people is gonna tell the
tale right you ran they know it's not
true doesn't matter what's true it
matters the story they tell when you're
gone what was it like being a dirty
nasty low-down bad guy you know it was
it was a real challenge to be that dirty
nasty low-down bad guy I've never had a
chance to do that before and it was
definitely a challenge
solo tonight uh yeah rolling solo on the
red carpet right now right now yeah yeah
I think because yeah yeah no no good you
can does you think because you don't
look don't look over there Catherine
does this great thing with pedigree and
because of that she can't go on the red
carpet tonight it's a weird thing I
don't know
the point is we're having a great time
go see the kid it's a good movie it's a
great movie it is a great it's a Western
if you only see one movie this weekend
you know make it Captain Marvel but if
you see a second movie or Captain Marvel
showed up go check out the kid is little
movie and it's really really great can
we also talk about your little lambs and
when you're upset what explained the
lamb oh well I have a farm I have a farm
in its lambing season right now many
people might not know this but lambs at
least the type of lambs that I have the
Sheep that I have they breed
once a year and they give birth once a
year so it's a season and we've got
about we had about 40 pregnant use men
so that means about 60 lambs and they're
all coming at the same time so that's my
obsession is if we're neat we're
knee-deep in lamb
[Music]